The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
ERIK DEMAINE: All right,
welcome back to 6.851.
We continue our theme
of time travel today.
Before I get started, I
wanted to briefly talk
about the project,
which I forgot
to talk about in lecture one.
Project is sort of the focus of
your evaluation in the class,
other than problems
sets inscribing,
it's supposed to be
the bulk of the work.
Project can be
theoretical, trying
to solve an open problem.
You don't have to succeed.
If you want to do that, you
should come to the open problem
sessions.
Could be a survey of
things, especially not
covered in class, or not
covered in class in much detail.
Look at a few papers.
Could be an implementation of
one of these data structures.
A lot of the data structures
we're talking about here
have never been implemented.
We don't know how well
they perform in practice,
and it'd cool to find out.
Many of them have though,
so you should do one
that hasn't been done already.
Those are the main
project types.
There will in a
month or so, there
will be a project proposal
deadline where you
have to pick what you're doing.
And then the project itself
is due last day of classes.
And in the last
few lectures, there
will be project presentations.
So you'll also have to
give a talk about it.
You can do group projects.
And for more people we
expect more stuff to be done,
that's all.
Otherwise unconstrained.
So in time travel land,
I guess the most sort
of physically
realistic physics land,
if time travel is
branching universes
where if you make a
change in the past
you get a totally new universe.
That's full persistence.
That's last class.
Today we're going to do the
more science fiction-y approach
to time travel, which
is you can-- like in
Back to the Future.
You can go back in
time, make a change,
and then return to the
present and see all the
intervening-- the result of
all the intervening things that
happen meanwhile.
A fun example of this,
if you haven't seen it,
is the movie Time
Cop, where there's
this guy going back
in time, trying
to fight evil time travelers.
And when he returns
to the present,
sometimes, like the
whole time travel
service is starting to fail.
And there's this worry
that he'll never be
able to return to the present.
So anyway, we want to do
that with the data structure.
So this is the idea
of retroactivity.
In general, we think of a data
structure as having a timeline.
We're going to maintain one
linear timeline of updates.
So here's time.
And the idea is, well, maybe at
time 0 you do an insert of 7.
And then at time 1, you
maybe did an insert of 3.
And then at time 2,
you did a delete-min.
OK, what's that spell?
Or, at the end you have--
right now, you'd have
just the element 7.
In general, every data structure
you can think of is this.
Now normally, we're always
appending to the timeline
that's working in the present.
You're doing operations
on the present.
But we'd like to allow--
with retroactive data
structures you can
go back in time, say
right at the beginning of
time, and say actually I
meant to put, at time minus 1, I
meant to do something insert 4.
Or actually, insert 2 would
be a little more interesting.
Insert 2 is interesting,
because that actually
changes what the delete-min
operation would have done.
And so I want to
go back in time,
do this, and then return to
the present, say what's my data
structure look like now.
I want to be able to do
the regular queries I can.
So let's say you can do
queries at the present.
This is now.
And you can do queries here.
And I want to be able to
add and remove operations.
Update operations at any time.
So that's what's called a
partially retroactive data
structure.
So like persistence, we
have partial and full.
So in general, we're going
to have insert at a given
time, a given update.
Delete the operation
at a given time.
And query.
And I'm going to
use capital letters
to denote retroactive operations
and lower case letters
to denote regular operations.
So it's intentional.
This is an uppercase insert.
This is a lowercase insert.
So we're inserting an insert
at time, the time before 0.
What exactly does
time mean here?
We're not going to work with
that too much directly today.
You can think of them
as just being integers.
But it gets awkward if you just
keep inserting new operations
to do in between 1 and 2.
There aren't very many
integers between 1 and 2.
One easy solution to this is
use the order maintenance data
structure that we mentioned
in the last class, where
you basically are
maintaining a linked list
and you're able to insert
new times in between any two
given times.
And you can still do order
queries in constant time.
But I mean, if you
don't mind logs
you could just store the
times in a binary search tree.
That's an easy way to do it.
We're not really going to
worry about that too much here.
What we're interested
here is how do we
maintain the sort
of side effects
of doing this operation
earlier in time,
computing all of this,
or chain reactions that
would have happened meanwhile,
sort of butterfly effect.
All right, I want to define
partial retroactivity
means queries are always
done at the present.
Let's say t equals
infinity or now.
This is what you might
call the Q model,
if you're a Star Trek fan.
You can exist in all time
simultaneously, do updates
whenever you feel
like it, do queries
whenever you feel like it.
All right model clear.
Now as you might
expect, this is hard.
You can't always do
retroactivity super well.
But we'll talk about our
situations you can do well
and what you can do in general.
Go to an easy case, which
is still fairly interesting.
Suppose you have
commutative updates,
meaning x followed by y is the
same thing as y followed by x.
This would be great if
I could reorder updates,
because then I don't really care
about the sequence of updates,
as long as I'm only
querying the final results.
If I want to do an
update in the past--
this would not be an example
of commutative-- delete-min
and insert are not commutative.
But if I was just doing
insert and delete for example,
delete 7, whatever,
then inserting 2 here
is the same thing as
inserting 2 at the end,
as long as I'm only
querying the end.
So this would be an easy case
for partial retroactivity.
If my updates are commutative,
then inserting an operation
at time t is the same thing as
inserting that operation now,
at the end of time.
That's for inserts.
But if I want to
also be able to--
for retroactive inserts,
I should say, capital I.
If I want to be able to
do retroactive deletes,
I need something else.
I need some way--
I still want to only work
in the present, if I can.
And for that I need inversion.
I have invertible updates.
If there is some way to,
given an operation x,
compute a new operation x
inverse, that does the reverse,
and that's equivalent
to nothing,
then deleting an operation
is the same thing as doing
the inverse.
And if you have
also commutativity--
so I'm adding these two
constraints-- then delete t
some operation is the same thing
as inserting now that operation
inverse.
So that's-- if I have
both of these properties,
then partial
retroactivity is trivial.
I just do everything
in the present.
May not seem very exciting, but
it solves a bunch of problems
already for free.
So for example, hashing.
If you want a dynamic
hash table or dictionary,
and you want to be able to
make retroactive changes,
it really doesn't matter whether
you make them in the past
or in the present.
I'm assuming a little bit here
that you don't, for example,
clobber a key and write
to the same key twice.
Then the order would matter.
But if you store all copies of
all keys, then this is true.
Slightly more
interesting, if you
have an array with the
operation add delta
to a given array element.
So if I had an assignment here,
then the order would matter.
But if I have only
addition or subtraction,
that's fine, because
addition and subtraction
are commutative.
So I can do that.
Not terribly exciting,
as you might imagine.
We're going to get to much
more interesting examples.
But a natural question here is
what about full retroactivity?
So partial's nice.
But if I have such
an easy setup,
can I achieve full
retroactivity?
It's not so obvious because
now working in the present,
it's not correctly
reflecting the past.
To do that, we need--
we cannot do it in
general, we don't know how.
But there is a situation
where we do know how.
First I'll define
a search problem.
The search problem is--
you've seen many
examples of this
in your algorithmic lifetime--
I maintain a set S of objects--
we don't know what they are--
subject to insert, delete,
and some kind of search query.
And I want to focus in on the
types of queries we allow.
So this in particular,
insert and delete
are commutative and invertible.
They are each other's inverses.
So n queries are queries.
This is really just a
constraint on updates.
So search problems fall
into this easy class.
So in particular,
it covers hashing.
Fine, that's a general
class of problems.
Here's a slightly less
general class of problems,
which are sort of well-studied.
The old geometric data
structures literature.
Decomposable search problems.
This is a concept
from 1980 revitalized.
I should mention this
retroactive paper
is pretty recent.
I think the journal
version appeared in 2007.
I have 2003 and 2007 here.
So those are the two
versions of the paper.
So what's a decomposable
search problem?
Same thing, but the query
is of a particular flavor,
has a particular structure.
If I want to do a query on the
union of two sets, a and b,
it's the same thing as doing
the query on the two sets
individually and then combining
them with some function.
This is a constraint
on what the query is.
The problem is still this.
I still want to do a
query on the entire set.
But I just know this fact,
that if I could somehow
solve the query
on smaller sets, I
could combine them into the
union using this f function.
For some, let's say this can
be computed in constant time.
That's a decomposable
search problem.
For example, suppose I have
a set of points in the plane.
And I want to know, given
a query point, what's
the nearest point in my set?
So it would be dynamic
nearest neighbor.
If I could compute the nearest
neighbor among one subset
of the points, and
the nearest neighbor
among a different subset, I can
compute the nearest neighbor
among the union just by
taking the min of the two.
Doesn't matter whether
a and b overlap.
That will still give
the right answer.
Sort of a min over all things.
I have some other examples.
Successor on a line.
If I'm given a
query point, I want
to know what the next, the
nearest item after it is.
That's sort of like
one-sided nearest neighbor.
Yeah, point location, we'll
get to that in the future.
Don't want to time
travel too much.
OK, so some property-- some
queries have this property.
Some don't.
If they do-- and we have
commutative and invertability--
I claim full retroactivity
becomes easy.
Relatively easy.
Log factor overhead.
So that's what I
wanted to show you.
Full retro for decomposable
search problems.
Decomposable search
problems are automatically
computed of an
invertible, so I don't
need to write that constraint.
In log-- I have n here,
but I think I mean m--
overhead.
It's a multiplicative factor.
m here is the number of
retroactive operations
you're doing.
So it's the size
of the timeline.
OK, we're going to do that
via something called a segment
tree, which was introduced
in the same paper that
dealt with decomposable search
problems by Bentley and Saxe
in 1980.
They weren't thinking
about time travel.
Retroactively their
result is useful.
So what's a segment tree?
It's a tree.
Let me draw my favorite picture.
Draw this many times in
this class, I'm sure.
I would like to build a balanced
binary search tree on time.
Leaves will be time.
Here's time.
And the idea is, well, if I
have my operations, my updates--
which are what the things
that live on time are--
are inserts and deletes.
And so if I look at an
element, at some point
it might be inserted.
At some point later
it might be deleted.
I'm going to assume every
element is inserted and deleted
only once.
Otherwise, if it
happens multiple times,
think of them as
different elements.
Then every element exists
for an interval of time.
So for example, maybe
I have an element
that exists for this
interval of time.
Maybe it gets inserted here
and then gets deleted here.
How should I represent
that interval in my tree?
Let's call this element a.
Well, if I draw a
complete binary tree,
there there's an
obvious way to represent
that interval, which is as the
union of these four intervals.
If you think of this
node as representing
the interval of
all of its leaves,
descendant leaves, then
I could put a here.
And I could put a here,
and here, and here.
I do that for all my elements.
This picture's going
to get messy quickly.
Let me just do one more example.
So maybe I have an
element from here to here.
Then I'm going to
call that element b.
Then I'll put b here.
And I'll put b here.
So always putting it
is as high as I can.
I don't want to put b or a in
all the leaves it appears in,
because that would be a
linear number of leaves.
If I do it like
this, there's only
log n subtrees I care
about, representing
the interval as a union of log
n subtree aligned intervals.
OK, now the real picture is
slightly messier than this.
I drew a nice,
complete, perfect tree.
In reality, you're inserting
new operations in here.
And so you've actually
got to maintain
this as a balanced
binary search tree.
So use a red-black tree, AVL
tree, or pick your favorite.
As long as it stays balanced,
you can still do this.
It'll be a little less
obvious how to do rotations,
but let's not worry about
rotations right now.
Now I want to do a query.
What's a query look like?
Well, I care about
all the things done up
to a certain time.
Or really I care
about who exists.
Let's say I want to do a
query on an array here.
That's maybe not so exciting.
Let's do a query here.
I want to know at
this time who exists,
and perform the
query on that time.
So really, I'm asking
about everything
done in this interval,
from the beginning of time
to my query time t.
So here's query of t.
Now we don't know
what the query is.
We just know it's on the set.
And we know that is decomposable
in this way by a set union.
So the idea is, well I'll do the
query on this data structure,
because that represents
whatever existed at that time.
And then I'll do the query
on this data structure,
because that represents
the things that
existed before that.
That doesn't look so great.
OK, so I need to put
each element in log n
different nodes in
here, such that I
can answer a query by looking
at log n different nodes.
And a query is asking about
what are all the things that
exist at this time.
So here it would be ab.
Over here it would be nothing.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you're
querying, the time
correspond to
particular [INAUDIBLE]..
Then you can query all
the data structures--
ERIK DEMAINE: OK, maybe I was
just doing the queries wrong.
Good, I think
that's a good idea.
I guess I'm asking about
querying this time.
So which node should I do?
All the ancestors.
I see.
Claim that does it.
Gotta think about it.
AUDIENCE: And then
you carry [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: That
definitely gets a and b.
That looks good.
All right, exercise to
prove that this works.
I think that is right.
So it's an asymmetry
between queries and updates.
For updates, you basically
partition the interval.
AUDIENCE: What happens to
a very short-lived element
at the very end of
the time travel?
[INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: So
maybe this works.
I'll think about
it offline and I'll
send email if it doesn't work.
But I think this is right.
So for query, you walk up time.
And I'm going to query each
of these data structures.
Now this is a logarithmic
factor overhead,
both in time and space, because
each element might be stored
in log n different structures.
Or what are in these
nodes, by the way?
That is your data structure,
the non-retroactive version.
So we're storing the
non-radioactive data structure
on these guys in order to--
when I add-- if I
modify a's interval,
I delete it from
all the places that
used to be in and then
reinsert it into all the places
it's now in.
So I'm doing inserts
and deletes on log n
of those non-retroactive
data structures.
OK, and then I combine with
f which is constant time.
So only log factor
overhead on the queries.
OK, a little harder
than I thought.
So full retro,
full retroactivity,
but in this relatively
simple special case.
Let's talk about
the general case.
There's an obvious way to do
full retroactivity, which is--
let's say partial retroactivity.
I want to know what
happened in the present.
The obvious thing to do is write
down all the changes you made.
And then if you want to
make a retroactive change,
you roll back, do your change,
and then replay everything
that happened meanwhile.
So this is the rollback method.
So if I need to go back in time
by a factor of r, by r time
units, I pay a factor
of r overhead in time.
And space is reasonable.
You just have to remember
everything that happened.
This is pretty obvious.
Also old.
Unfortunately,
it's about the best
we can do in general,
depending on your exact model.
So we add the lower bound.
This is kind of a fun result
from a philosophy standpoint,
philosophy of time travel.
It's essentially saying
that Back to the Future
is impossible.
I know, it's sad but true.
And there's a good movie
about this called Retroactive.
This is a very unknown
movie, from '97,
or so, where they play through
this sequence of events.
And then there's a time
machine which brings them,
I forget, an hour into the past.
And then they have to
relive those events.
And they can make changes.
But they have to spend
all that time until they
get to the time machine again.
They still didn't get it
right, so they go back in time.
And the movie repeats
like six times or so,
until they finally get it right.
Or I shouldn't, whatever,
forget the ending actually.
So that's realistic in that
we know from persistence,
we can remember the past.
And we can jump back into the
past and then just relive it.
And maybe make
changes along the way.
But the claim is you can't
do that any more efficiently
than replaying all of those
events, in the worst case,
and I think even in real life.
Should include the worst case.
So let me tell you why.
All we need to live
in our universe
for this lower bound to hold
is a very simple computer.
It's a computer with
two registers, x and y.
They start at zero.
AUDIENCE: Question.
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: When you say that
the overhead can be necessary,
does that mean that
it's sometimes not--
ERIK DEMAINE: The can be is
relative to the data structure.
So there is a data
structure where
you're guaranteed to need
order r in the worst case.
And probably the average case
in all sorts of bad things.
Yeah, so there are
some data structures,
like these ones, where
you can do better.
And this is for
partial retroactivity.
But then there are
some data structures,
like the one I'm going
to describe to you,
that you cannot do better.
So here are my operations.
I can set x to a value.
I can add a value to y.
I can compute the product of
x and y and put it into y.
And then I have a query,
which is what is y.
So this is one of the simplest
computers ever designed.
A very basic calculator.
But it lets us do--
Here's what the operations
I'm going to do.
First operation-- this
is in order of time.
First I will add a into y.
Then I will compute the product.
Then I will compute--
then I will add a
and minus 1 to y.
Then I will compute the product.
And then at the end, I
will add a zero to y.
What does that do?
Mathematicians.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE:
Polynomial evaluation.
This is equivalent to
computing a n, x to the n--
well, I guess capital X
to the n, a n minus 1,
x to the n minus 1, a0.
OK, I didn't set X
at the beginning.
But whatever X was, this
sequence of operations
will evaluate this polynomial.
This is called Cramer's rule
for evaluating that polynomial.
Just keep multiplying
by X in each round,
adding on the next coefficient.
OK, so the result--
this I'm just going to
do at the beginning.
It's like regular operations.
And now I'm going to do
things like insert at time 0
that X equals some value.
I'm just going to keep--
first I'll put it here, then
right after, then right after--
keep doing those insertions.
I completely change what X is.
And so I change where I'm
evaluating this polynomial.
And claim is you
really can't do that
any faster than
reevaluating the polynomial.
In a history independent
algebraic decision tree model--
which I don't want to
define precisely, but maybe
computation tree
would be better.
Anyway, this is just you draw a
tree of all the possible things
you could do.
And the things you can do are
additions, multiplications,
subtractions, divisions,
all field operations.
So for any field, this would
work with reals, would also,
should work for
integers module LP.
Any fields.
And the interesting part is
independent of preprocessing
of the coefficients, you can
stare at those coefficients
however long you like.
In the worst case, you need
mega n field operations,
where n is the degree
of the polynomial.
So this is a known
result from 2001.
And so it tells you that each
of these retroactive operations,
it's n time units in the past.
And you need order n
time to complete it.
Even though these
operations can be
solved in constant time each.
So it's a factor n loss.
Now this is a particular
model of computation.
It implies something like an
integer or a random access
machine, where you can have
arrays, I don't really care.
But as long as the
way that you're
manipulating these objects
are with field operations,
you're in trouble.
OK, but there are conceivably
other things you could do.
If these numbers
are integers maybe
I could split their
bits into parts
and do crazy things with them.
That's something we'll get
to later on in the class.
Even then, you can't do so well.
I guess I'll briefly tell
you this because there's
an interesting lower balance.
Oh sorry, interesting
open problem.
Cell-probe model, something
we'll get into in a deeper way
later on in this class.
But it just says
how many objects,
how many words of memory do
you need to read in order
to solve your problem?
So that's a lower bound on time.
No matter how you're
computing with those numbers,
how many of the objects,
how many of the integers
do you need to read?
Not necessarily just the
ai's You could split them
into parts, do all
kinds of preprocessing,
make a hash table,
build whatever
data structure you want.
How many words of that data
structure do you need to read?
And the claim is at least square
root of r divided by log r.
So roughly square root
of r, open problem,
is can you get something
like r again in this model?
So this is a very powerful
model, not at all realistic.
But if you can prove a
lower bound in this model,
then it holds basically all
models you could ever think of.
So here's a data
structure-- or here's
the proof of this lower bound.
Data structure
maintains n words.
I should say typically
in this class,
a word is an integer
of let's say log n--
I'll be more precise.
w bits.
w is at least log n.
We'll talk about
this a lot more later
in the class when we get
to integer data structures.
But if you were wondering what
a word means, there it is.
And the operations, the
updates you are allowed to do
are arithmetic operations.
So it's generalization
of this problem.
You can do addition,
multiplication, division,
just basic stuff.
So that's the data structure
we're trying to do.
And at the end you can query
what is the value of this word.
And now what are we going to do?
Before we did polynomial
evaluation in that model.
Now what I'm going to
do is compute FFT, fast
Fourier transform.
If you know how
to do that great.
If not, it's an n
log n algorithm.
So it's an n log in
operations you do.
I'm just going to write them
down as my sequence of updates.
At the end I have the
fast Fourier transform.
And the retroactive
thing I'm going to do
is set all of these words,
all the xi's, and name them.
Which changes the input to
the fast Fourier transform.
And it turns out that dynamic
fast Fourier transform,
where changing one of the
words, xi, you can show,
or it has been shown--
we're not going to
prove this here--
requires at least square
root of n cell-probes.
So this is about--
if you change one thing in
a fast Fourier transform,
it doesn't change
everything, necessarily.
But the claim is
that you need to look
at least root n of
the things again,
in order to figure out what
happened, how the FFT changed.
So I mention this mostly
as an interesting question
of whether you can come up
with a better lower bound
in this data structure.
Ideally taking some
existing lower bound,
plugging it in to this kind
of retroactive framework,
and getting what you want.
Enough about the bad news.
I want to go to
positive results again.
So we had a very
simple thing here.
Let's try something
that's somewhere
in between, where there
are chain reactions,
but it's not impossible.
So in general, if
you're building--
if you have a data structure
that represents an arbitrary
computer, you're
basically hosed.
If you have a data
structure where
the operations can be
arbitrarily reordered, pretty
easy.
So our intermediate setting will
be priority queues, the example
I showed at the very beginning.
So on a priority
queue, I'm going
to think about two operations,
insert and delete-min.
This is interesting
because delete-min depends
on what the current state is.
So if I insert
something early on,
it can change every delete-min
that happens thereafter,
and completely change what
happens at the end of the data
structure.
So the claim is
we can solve this
with log n time per
operation, per partially
retroactive operation.
It's pretty good because
in this model, which--
what model are we in here?
I guess pointer machine
would be a reasonable model?
Log n is the best you can
hope for a priority queue.
I guess comparison model
is more relevant then.
So you can use priority
queues to sort.
So log n is the best you can
do for regular priority queues.
And so to do it also
partially retroactive
is pretty interesting.
How do we do this?
Well, I don't want to draw
a picture of what these data
structures look like.
My picture is keyspace is
going to be the y-axis,
and time is the x-axis.
So if someone comes along
and does an insertion,
they do the insertion at some
time with some key value.
And so I'm going
to think of that
as a rightward pointing
ray, because at that point
that element exists.
And if nothing happens, it
will exist for the end of time.
The problem would be if
someone comes along and does
a delete-min.
A delete-min is going to be a
ray shooting up from infinity,
because you always want
to delete the smallest
possible thing.
So whatever this
ray hits first, that
is the thing that gets deleted.
So I want to keep--
I want to draw all those
rays for the delete-mins.
So this is a delete-min.
And this is an insert.
So I have rightward
rays for insertions.
They start at some point.
And I have upward
rays from infinity.
In general, I'm going to
get a bunch of L shapes.
And the L's will be non
crossing in a legitimate picture
of an execution
of the algorithm.
AUDIENCE: The vertical stuff is
when you're taking the min out?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah the
vertical lines are delete-mins.
They're coming from below.
They're taking whatever the
smallest thing is that exists.
So think about like
this time right here.
Right now these four elements
are in the data structure.
You do a delete-min, you
delete the smallest one.
So this guy dies.
But the three others continue.
Maybe there'll be some
elements that just exist.
They don't get deleted.
So it's not entirely L's.
That's sort of a
half of an L. So you
might have some L's like that
that just go off to infinity.
But everyone that's
in an L, this
is the insertion that made it.
These are the delete-mins
that deleted it.
We're not going to do arbitrary
deletes, just delete-mins.
It's hard enough.
OK, problem clear?
So I want to maintain this.
Let me show you what goes wrong,
the hard part about this data
structure.
Let's say I do an insert here.
New insertion.
Well, that means that this
delete-min would have returned
this guy instead of this one.
So this one would actually
continue to exist.
So then this delete-min
would have deleted
this guy instead of that one.
So this guy continues to exist.
So this continues to the right.
This starts exist
until this delete-min,
and now this one exists.
OK, and then this one
exists for the rest of time.
In general, you do a
single retroactive insert,
everything could change.
Or a linear number
of guys could change.
So if you want to maintain this
picture, you're in trouble.
You get an omega r lower bound.
So we're not going to
maintain this picture.
But we're going to
keep it in our minds,
vaguely, that we wanted to know
something like this picture.
What we really need to know
is that this element now
exists in the data structure.
If I'm just doing partial
retroactivity, what
I care about is who
exists at the end of time.
So I'm doing an insert
at a given time t,
with a given key x.
And if life was good, you
know, if I was commutative,
then that would be
equivalent to inserting
that key x at the end of time.
But it's not.
Instead I have to
figure out what
key gets inserted
at the end when
I insert this key at this time.
And similarly for
adding a delete-min.
I won't try to draw that,
but exactly the same kind
of chain reactions can happen.
OK, so we're going to
do this in log n time.
How do we do it?
So I'm going to focus on the
insertion case, inserting--
the double insertion case--
inserting an insert operation.
I guess I'm going to switch
notation and call the keys k,
instead of x.
It doesn't matter.
OK, what I'd like
to know is that when
I do this insertion, what gets
inserted into the final Q?
I'm going to call
that Q now, being
the the present, the future,
whatever you want to call it.
I claim this is
what gets inserted.
If you look at all the keys
that get deleted from now on,
and you look at the
key you're inserting,
you take the max
of all those, that
will be the one that survives.
That's pretty obvious.
The annoying thing is this is
really hard to think about.
Because who gets deleted
is something that
is a chain reaction effect.
What we'd really like to have
is the word inserted there,
because we know what
things get inserted when.
Those are the operations.
We just maintain the list of
operations, we'd know that.
Deleted is a lot
harder to think about.
So we need a Lemma
that tells us--
there's a nice equation that
simplifies this formula for us,
or this computation.
For that we need the
notion of a bridge.
A very simple idea.
A bridge at time
t is a time when
everything that's
currently in the queue
will finally be in the queue.
So this is a bridge.
This is a bridge.
Because these elements
exist for the rest of time.
This is a bridge.
OK, these are basically--
interesting stuff
happens between bridges.
Bridges are the points of rest
when things are kind of boring.
We'll need this for
the next statement.
And the other claim is
it's easy to maintain
where the bridges are.
That's not a big surprise.
Because there's no chain
reactions at the bridges.
So if I have a time
t that I care about--
I want to compute this
formula for time t--
what I do is find
the preceding bridge.
Call it t prime.
This is like-- an
arbitrary time t like here,
we're in the middle
of some action.
I want to know what
that action is.
So I want to go to the
preceding blue line.
So that's t prime.
If my query is here,
t prime will be there.
Then, what I want to know is
this max of k prime where k
prime is deleted after time t.
I should say greater equal
to t, instead of after,
a little more precise.
Claim this equals the
max over all k prime
not in the final queue,
because those guys obviously
still exist.
Where k prime is inserted
at time greater than
or equal to t prime.
So basically I can turn the word
deleted into the word inserted,
if I change t to t prime.
And I also have to exclude
the guys at the top.
So we're looking at a
particular time like here.
I want to know who
are the things that
are deleted after that.
Well, this is deleted.
This is deleted.
All these guys
are deleted after.
I'm going to rewind to t
prime and say, well, you
know there are these
guys that they survive.
They obviously
don't get deleted.
But if you ignore the guys
that end up in the final queue,
the guys that get
deleted after time t
are the same as the ones that
get inserted after t prime.
That's the claim.
Or actually, that set of
elements is not the same,
but the max will be the same.
That's all I care about.
I only want to know the max.
The max among all
the ones deleted here
is this upper uppermost segment.
And that's the same as
the max among all the guys
that are inserted after here.
So it's really just a
claim about this one being
inserted after this bridge.
I won't prove this Lemma.
It's just, you think about
it for long enough, it
becomes obvious.
Leave it at that.
Now we can do some
data structures,
because now we have something
that we can reasonably
hope to maintain.
So maintaining
bridges, one thing--
Yeah, actually kind
of an important thing.
So here's where
we're going to store.
We're going to store the current
Q as a balanced binary search
tree.
OK, that's not very exciting.
Though the hard part
is to figure out how
Q now is changing at each step.
But this will allow us
to do arbitrary queries
on the final result
We want to store a balanced
binary search tree whose leaves
represent insertions.
So lowercase insertions.
So that's all of the
rightward arrows.
And they're are going
to be sorted by time.
Not by a key value.
OK, and I'm going to augment
that balanced binary search
tree with a fun
value for every node
in the balanced
binary search tree.
I want to know max
of all the keys
not currently in
the queue, or not
presently in the queue
at the end of time.
That changes is very slowly,
so this is easy to maintain.
Among all the keys
that are inserted
in the subtree rooted at x.
OK, that's basically this
value, which I want to maintain,
but split up over a subtree.
And so that lets me
easily compute this value
by taking the max of log n
of these values at any time.
OK, then we store another
balanced binary search tree
where the leaves
are all the updates.
Again they will be
ordered by time.
And they will be augmented.
In each node, I'm going
to store a number which
is 0 plus 1 or minus 1.
It's going to be
0 for an insert.
This is at the leaf
level because the leaves
correspond to updates.
If that key ends up
in the final queue.
So those we just ignore.
It's going to be plus 1 for
any other kind of insert.
Inserting a key where
k is not in Q now.
And it's going to be
minus 1 for a delete-min.
I'm going to store this.
And we're going to
have subtree sums.
So this is fun
with augmentation.
Why do I do all that?
Because if I store
all these numbers,
it becomes really easy
to detect bridges.
I claim.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
ERIK DEMAINE: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So, what we're
looking for is basically
we know how the cascade
went in any given--
ERIK DEMAINE: We want to compute
how one of these cascades
will end.
AUDIENCE: And so we just always
maintain that information?
ERIK DEMAINE: We're always
going to maintain what's here.
We can't afford to
maintain this whole picture
because it changes too much.
But we want to--
we're given this.
We want to know the
result of the cascade,
without having to do all
that stuff in the middle.
Yeah, that's our goal.
And I claim-- this
is a lot of text.
But I claim that
this information
is enough to do
that in log n time.
So let me try to convince you.
AUDIENCE: So are you storing
several binary searches?
ERIK DEMAINE: I'm storing three.
I'm storing one that
represents the final result.
I'm storing one that's just
looking at the insertions.
I'm storing one that
looks at all the updates.
I maintain all three, and
you can cross-link them
all you want.
OK, I claim a bridge
is now a prefix
of updates summing to zero,
according to this measure.
Because inserts and deletes,
when they all cancel out--
and if we ignore the things
that finally end up there,
the periods of rest,
when no one is active
that will eventually
get deleted,
that's exactly when everyone
to the left has been deleted
or will survive to the end.
So these guys counts as
zeros, so we ignore those.
Each of these
corresponds to plus 1.
corresponds to a minus 1.
So these have all
canceled out by now.
And when this prefix
sum, which is everything
up to a given point, is
zero, then that is a bridge.
What this lets you do
is if you have some--
you have this
binary search tree.
You have some query time t,
which corresponds to a leaf.
And now I want to know what
is the preceding bridge?
I want to know t prime, the
bridge proceeding time t.
Then basically I
walk up this tree
and find the preceding moments--
I actually have to first walk
down to compute all the sums.
So hanging off on
the left of this path
are all these times in the past.
And I say well, if the sum of
all of those subtree sums, sum
of all the values in those
leaves, if that's 0 then
we're already at a bridge.
If not, I basically compute
the preceding point where
this sum up to that point is 0.
And that should be
relatively obvious how to do.
It's a regular kind of
walking up the tree.
So log n time I can find
the preceding bridge.
Because I have all
these subtrees sums
I can do that by a tree walk.
OK, then it just says
here, "And then you
can compute the change to Qnow."
How do we compute
the change to Qnow?
We have to compute this
max of all the keys
that are inserted
after time t prime.
So this was the
tree of all updates.
And we have another tree, which
is just the tree of insertions.
And so if we
cross-link time-- so
we find t prime, where
the prefix sum is zero.
We map over to t prime here.
And again we get a
root to leaf path.
And now we look at all of
the elements hanging off
the right side.
Those are all the
elements that are
inserted after time t prime.
And I just take
the max of those.
So I guess I didn't
write it, but I
need to store our subtree--
oh no, I store this.
Right, this is what I want.
For every subtree,
I want to know
the max of the things
in that subtree,
but ignoring the guys
that are in Qnow.
I take all those maxes
on all those subtrees.
And I can find what element
gets inserted into Qnow in log n
time.
Then, of course, I have to
update all this information.
And I don't want
to spend any more
time on this, no pun intended.
You have to-- then Qnow changes.
And so you've got to update all
these values and these values.
But the claim is that you can
do all that in log n time.
It's not hard.
OK, that's priority queues.
So I know that was a
little bit tedious.
But this is sort of--
it's not quite the coolest
thing we know how to do,
but it was the first
cool thing we knew how
to do in the retroactive world.
It's this nice borderline
where it looks scary.
There are linear-sized
chain reactions.
Yet we can still deal
with them in log n time.
So not quite the worst
case, but also not easy.
So in general, if you want
a retroactive data structure
for your favorite
data structure,
you're going to have to
think along these lines,
see whether you can maintain
something reasonable.
Let me tell you briefly about
other problems, other data
structures that we've looked
at, and other people have
looked at.
So a simple one is a queue,
first in, first out first in,
last out.
One of those.
I've got stacks too, probably.
You can do constant time
partial retroactivity.
Log n time full
retroactivity for a deque.
I mentioned this last time
where you can insert and delete
from either end.
We can do log n full
retroactivity for union-find.
You have a bunch of sets.
You want to be able
to take their union.
And given an element you want
to know which set it's in.
It's sometimes taught in 6046.
The best thing we know is
log m fully retroactive.
Priority queue we
already talked about.
But--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: Is
there a question?
Priority queue, we already
did partial retroactivity.
But what if you want
full retroactivity?
This is pretty much
an open problem.
Best thing we know is square
root of m to m's log n.
This is via-- we have
a general result that
says if you have anything
that's partially retroactive,
you can make it
fully retroactive
at a huge cost of
square root of m factor.
So you could take what we have,
make it fully retroactive.
Full.
AUDIENCE: Is there any
difference when you're
talking about n [INAUDIBLE]
ERIK DEMAINE: n, I
think it's supposed
to be the current size
of the data structure.
I'm not actually
sure what that means
with a retroactive operation.
I'll just make them all m's.
I think that's safer.
Other question or same one?
OK good, thank you.
OK, let me tell you about
the most important problem
in this field.
This is actually
what motivated us
to define retroactivity,
which is a particular problem,
retroactive successor.
So successor problem is I want
to be able to insert and delete
keys in one dimension.
And given a query
key, I want to know
what is the next key
greater or equal to it.
This is something
you can do in log n
time with a balanced
binary search tree.
There's lots of
other ways to do it,
which we will get to
later in this class.
But what if I want to
do it fully retroactive?
Partially retroactive
is really easy,
because this is
a search problem.
So I can definitely do log
m partial retroactivity.
In fact, it is a--
I just use a regular binary
search tree, or whatever.
In fact, it is a
decomposable search problem.
So I get full
retroactivity, no problem.
But I pay a log
factor, so I get log
squared m, full retroactivity.
And so that's where we
left it, back in 2003.
But there's a new
result, which is
that you can actually get
log m without the square full
retroactivity.
This is a complicated result.
It's by Goran and Kaplan, 2009.
It uses fun techniques like
fractional cascading, which
is next lecture, and van Emde
Boas, which is lecture 11,
and various other tools.
So it's a little too
advanced to cover now.
But it's cool.
And it has lots of applications
in geometry, which we will
be talking about next class.
So hold your breath
for that, I guess.
Yeah.
I want to go to one
last topic, which
is a different kind
of retro activity
Nonoblivious retroactivity is
introduced by Acar, Blelloch,
Tangwongsan in 2007.
And it's basically
answering the question
"What about my queries?"
So we have this
timeline of updates.
And we've done
various operations
on our data structure,
which are the updates.
And we've considered how
those can be changed.
And then with queries, either
we're querying at the end
or querying in the middle.
But we're always getting
sort of instantaneous,
as the timeline exists
right now, here's what
the result of your query is.
But what if I want to do--
I mean, if I really-- normally
when I use a data structure,
I do some updates.
I do some queries.
I do a combination
of these things.
And to make life worse,
when I do a query,
the result of that
query probably
influences what updates
I do in the future.
So real use, I'll just
call that the algorithmic
use of a data structure.
Results of queries
influence updates,
what updates are going to do.
OK, and now this gets a
little dicey, because what
does influence mean?
We don't know, because
that's the user somehow
depends on these results.
So nonoblivious retroactivity is
trying to deal with this issue.
Can we get something reasonable?
So what we'd like to
do is say, oh I now
add an update over
here, retroactively.
So their updates are
the same, in some sense.
You can retroactively insert and
delete updates and queries now.
I'd like to know well, did the
result of this query change?
Maybe you can show--
at the data structure
level we can tell
did that query result change.
Maybe this one changed,
but this one did not.
What we'd like to
report to the user
is what is the first
query that changed,
because that's like the
first mistake that you made.
Like oh you know,
retroactively oops
I should have deposited
$100 back here.
And then these
queries which we're
checking whether the balance
was positive or negative,
some of their results might
change, some of them might not.
If they change, then
the algorithm has to--
I mean, it doesn't have
to rerun these operations,
because that's what
retroactivity buys for you.
But it has to say, oh well,
now this query has changed.
And then you have to rerun
the algorithm from that point.
But not necessarily entirely.
I mean, you look at
that and say, oh,
did that query actually
change anything?
This is now the algorithm.
Oh yeah, instead of this
update here, I would have made
a different update u prime.
Well, that's good, we
know how to do that.
That's a retroactive update.
So I can delete this
operation retroactively
and insert this one.
So in general, what we
assume the algorithm does is
it looks at the
first error, which is
reported by our data structure.
And then it then may
make various changes
from that point onward,
but always monotonically
left to right, as
if it was rerun
in the algorithm, but just
changing what needed to change,
until all the
errors are resolved.
All the queries have been
corrected to the right answers.
Then it can do
whatever it wants.
Then it can do retroactive
operation anytime in the past.
OK, so this is an assumption.
Assume once there's an error,
that the algorithm makes
changes, retroactive
updates, from left to right.
And also going to assume that
it does it at times less than
or equal to all errors.
So in general, you
have a timeline.
And then there are some errors
where bad queries were done.
Naturally, you
would go right here
and fix the first
error, because that
may influence other errors.
And maybe you have--
so then you make that change.
Maybe then that causes
some other changes
right after or
somewhere in between.
But then I don't want
to make a change here,
because that would be
depending on this result, which
was incorrect.
So first you have to fix this.
So you keep going to the right
and you visit all the stars.
That's this assumption.
This is a very different
kind of retroactivity.
I would say it's more about
maintaining this exact picture
of what's happening, but
being able to teleport over
the uninteresting stuff.
So in this picture, if
we're doing priority queues
like this, when I
make this change,
well, that query changes.
That query changes.
The delete-mins, the mins
that they're deleting change.
So here they were just updates.
But if there's also a query
here, which is what is the min,
then all of these query
values would change.
So you're forced
now to pay for that.
So in some sense,
it gets easier.
Let's say.
For a lot of problems this kind
of retroactivity is easier.
But for many problems,
it's also more useful.
So their example is what if you
want to do a dynamic Dijkstra?
So you have
Dijkstra's algorithm,
and then you say, oh, actually
this edge weight was wrong.
So you run Dijkstra's
algorithm once.
You've got a priority
queue in there telling you
which vertex is next.
And now you say, OK,
I changed this weight
at the beginning of time.
I don't want to have to
rerun Dijkstra entirely
if nothing changes.
Maybe that weight was
completely irrelevant.
If you just do a
retroactive update and see
did any of the query results
change, if they didn't change,
then great you have
the right answer.
If they did change,
the results change.
And so you have to know
for every wrong query
that oh, I really had to
change the shortest pathway.
It's not this, it's now this.
But hopefully,
you will only have
to change a very small
amount if your graph
didn't change in a big way.
So it's hard to proof results
about that, but at least
this would let you dynamize
almost any algorithm that's
using the data structure.
So it's easier, but useful for
that kind of transformation.
OK, let me give you an example,
which is priority queues.
There's a bunch of results in
their paper, but for symmetry.
Tell you about priority queues.
This will look completely
different, so don't worry.
Operations-- well, the
visual picture is the same,
but the data structuring is
all completely different.
They can do all
these things in log m
per retroactive operation.
Now there's no notion
of full and partial.
It's just nonoblivious
retroactivity.
I didn't write it here, but
the data structure always
maintains what is the
earliest error currently.
Maintain the earliest
in time error.
That error is a query that
used to return one result,
now returns a new result.
OK we have a similar picture.
So I cheated-- I've changed
things a little bit.
I didn't cheat.
It's just a slight discrepancy.
For retroactive, regular
retroactive, insert and
delete-min were
more interesting,
because then they
were chain reactions.
In this world you don't have
to combine delete and min.
You could consider
delete separate from min.
Because now, updates are
allowed to depend on queries.
So maybe you compute
a min and then
you decide to delete that thing.
If the min changes, well then,
the thing that got deleted
might also change.
That's the algorithm's choice.
What to do.
So in this new world of insert,
delete, and min, slightly more
general, if you look at an item,
it gets inserted at some time.
It might get deleted
at some time.
Sometimes it might
go off to infinity,
if it never gets deleted.
OK, this is our new picture of
the priority queue over time.
So again, this is the time axis.
And this is the key value.
So have some inserts, deletes.
They're all corresponding
points in here.
And then you have min queries,
which maybe I will draw in red.
So min query would be
something like this.
Give me what is the lowest
segment at this time.
So that's my sequence
of operations
is the projection onto
time, so there's this thing.
Then there's this query.
Then there's this insertion.
Then there's this deletion.
Then there's this query.
Min query, then
there's this insertion.
Then there's this query.
Then there's this deletion.
You get the idea.
But this is a way to
two-dimensionalize
that picture.
AUDIENCE: Can you delete
without the query?
ERIK DEMAINE: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Can you delete
without the query?
ERIK DEMAINE: You can delete
without a query in this model.
Make our life a
little bit harder.
Now what we need to support
are capital insert, and capital
delete, retroactive insert
and delete, of all three
of these operations.
Before it was just updates.
Now we can insert
and delete queries.
A little harder to think about.
But it can be done.
So for example, let's just--
I'm not going to
do all the cases,
because there's a lot of them.
Let's say I delete
this deletion.
OK, that means that this
will just go to the right.
OK, that's bad, because it
changes all of these queries.
All of these queries
are now incorrect.
We're just going to keep
the picture like this
and remember that
there are errors.
And we'll be able to
maintain at every moment what
is the next error.
The errors are these crossings.
Crossings are bad.
That means you have
the wrong picture.
But we'll wait for
the algorithm--
we'll tell the algorithm
this is the next crossing.
And it's going to have to fix
it by say deleting that query
and then reinserting it.
Then it will get
the correct result.
But it might do other
updates meanwhile.
So let's not try to fix them
all now because they may change.
Maybe they'll decide to
re-insert a deletion here
to do that, and then erase
all of those crossings,
if we're lucky.
You might also
insert an insertion.
That's basically the same
as deleting a deletion.
You get a whole
bunch of crossings.
Inserting an insertion
and deleting a deletion
are about the same.
So the other case is
inserting a deletion
or deleting an insertion.
So inserting a deletion.
Let's say that I
insert a deletion here.
So now suddenly this
thing ceases to exist.
All of this is gone.
We get not a crossing
error, but we
get what I'll call a
floating air, which
is that these guys are
currently returning something
that there's no segment there.
OK, so we can get crossing
errors and floating errors.
I want to give you enough
of this data structure
to show that actually you use
these data structures to solve
it.
So in that sense, it's
actually not that much easier.
I said it was easier,
but we're going
to need a retroactive successor
in order to solve this problem.
OK, some variants.
Man, who used this
colored chalk?
It's so hard to erase.
Let's say I want to maintain
the lowest leftmost crossing.
So in this picture, where I
have a bunch of crossings,
this is the one I want to
maintain, the bottom left one.
Now there's a bit
of a subtlety here,
which is do you do you
minimize y-coordinate
and then x-coordinate?
Or vice versa?
It turns out these
are the same thing.
I don't want to prove that here,
but because of this assumption
that we're always proceeding
monotonically left to right,
we have a nice invariant that if
you look at all the crossings,
they involve segments that
start to the left of all errors.
Because all the
changes we've made
are to the left of all
errors by this property.
And so it's really
just a whole bunch
of rays coming in from
negative infinity on the left,
and a whole bunch of rays
coming from minus infinity
on the bottom.
Sometimes the rays stop.
But if you look at
where they cross,
there's a uniquely defined
bottom left corner.
OK, so that's this picture.
Those rays might go different
amounts from either side,
but there is a single
lower left corner.
So we're going to maintain that.
And we're also going to maintain
the leftmost floating point,
floating error, on
each row separately.
So in each horizontal
line, like here,
we'll maintain that there's
a floating error here
for this row.
But we won't figure out
that one till later.
That just saves the
work we have to do.
OK, now let me show you an
operation let's do insert min.
So I want to--
I'm going to use
x for time here,
because it's a little
bit more intuitive.
X-coordinate is time.
Suppose I want to
insert a query.
This is actually an easy
case because there's
no chain reactions here.
It's going to be correct because
I'm doing the query right now.
This is basically a
fully retroactive query.
I'm adding a new
time, a new query,
and I want to know what is
the first ray that I hit.
How do I solve that?
So what's going on here is
I'm basically manipulating
these line segments.
I mean, the red lines don't
really affect this query.
They just might be incorrect.
But I don't care if
they're incorrect.
I just want to know
for this query, what
is the lowest segment?
So really, I have segments.
They're changing.
Inserting and deleting
endpoints of the segments.
And I want to know
from below, what is
the first segment that I hit?
This is called
upward ray-shooting.
Or vertical
ray-shooting, I guess,
would be the normal
phrasing, but I want
to be a little more specific.
Not downward upward.
Among dynamic segments.
This is a well-studied problem.
And conveniently, it can
be solved in log n time
preparation.
So you can modify segments and
do upward ray-shooting queries
in log n type preparation.
But you already knew that.
Good, you're nodding your head.
Because that is
retroactive successor,
if you think about it.
A retroactive insertion
operation in the past
is like its fully
retroactive successor.
That's this result.
Inserting an insertion,
that's like creating
a new left endpoint
point of a segment.
Inserting a deletion is like
creating a new right endpoint.
Deleting a deletion or
deleting an insertion,
you could use that
to move the endpoint.
So that's exactly dynamic
segments, horizontal segments.
And then shooting a ray is--
in general-- a general
ray-shooting query
is like this.
I can be not from
minus infinity,
be at an arbitrary point, and
ask, what do I hit upward next?
That is like at this time
doing a successor query.
OK, now this is a
special kind of successor
query, because it's always
from minus infinity.
So you might be able
to solve it easier.
But in particular, you can
solve it using this result.
So regular retroactivity
helps you do nonoblivious
retroactivity.
Cool.
We're out of time.
So I will just say, the
other cases are similar.
There's one other
thing you need to do,
which is in addition
to upward ray-shooting,
you have to do rightward
ray-shooting because
of things like this.
If I delete this
deletion, I want
to know what do I hit next.
So that's a rightward
ray-shooting
among dynamic segments,
which all happen
to start at minus infinity.
So it's again-- it's dynamic
ray-shooting, or successor
queries, but in x instead of y.
So with those tricks,
you can do all
of the cases of
inserting deleting,
deleting insertions,
inserting, all combinations
of those things.